bonjour Maxime l’écuelles je suis le
gérant des magasins Cash Converters nous
sommes une jeune PME avec 35 salariés le
premier magasin ouvert en 2010 à 5
Clotilde a suivi celui de Savannah à
Saint-Paul puis celui de Saint-André où
nous sommes aujourd'hui et enfin celui
qui vient juste d'ouvrir à Saint-Pierre
le 6 septembre à la vente qu'est-ce que
Cash Converters c'est des magasins
d'achat et de vente de matériel
d'occasion nous achetons l'ensemble des
produits sauf les meubles et les
vêtements donc l'informatique des jeux
des consoles
de
l'électroménager évidemment des bijoux
et nous les revenons au meilleur prix
avec une garantie
alors aujourd'hui nous recherchons un
acheteur vendeur sur le magasin de
Saint-Paul alors qu'est-ce que le métier
d'acheteur vendeur c'est d'acheter aux
particuliers l'ensemble des produits qui
peut nous ramener donc tout sauf les
vêtements ça passe de la téléphonie
mobile aux ordinateurs partagent en
passant par l'électroménager la musique
la hi-fi la sono
les bijoux évidemment donc il y a une
connaissance produit importante à avoir
mais également savoir tester le produit
pour vérifier qu'il fonctionne bien et
ensuite pouvoir le mettre à la vente
évidemment vous serez appelé aussi à
être vendeur donc à savoir vendre le
produit accueillir le client connaître
toutes les spécificités du magasin du
logiciel c'est un métier très
intéressant très complet si vous êtes
motivé et que ce poste vous intéresse
n'hésitez pas contactez-nous gérant des
magasins Cash Converters nous sommes une
jeune PME avec 35 salariés le premier
magasin ouvert en 10 à 5 Clotilde a
suivi celui de Savannah à Saint-Paul
puis celui de Saint-André où nous sommes
aujourd'hui et enfin celui qui vient
juste d'ouvrir à Saint-Pierre le 6
septembre à la vente qu'est-ce que Cash
Converters c'est des magasins d'achat et
de vente de matériel d'occasion nous
achetons l'ensemble des produits sauf
les meubles et les vêtements donc
l'informatique des jeux des consoles
de
l'électroménager évidemment des bijoux
et nous les revendons aux meilleurs prix
avec une garantie
alors aujourd'hui nous recherchons un
acheteur vendeur sur le magasin de
Saint-Paul alors qu'est-ce que le métier
d'acheteur vendeur c'est d'acheter aux
particuliers l'ensemble des produits qui
peut nous ramener donc tout sauf les
vêtements ça passe de la téléphonie
mobile aux ordinateurs portables en
passant par l'électroménager la musique
là ici la sono
les bijoux évidemment donc il y a une
connaissance produit importante à avoir
mais également savoir tester le produit
pour vérifier qu'il fonctionne bien et
ensuite pouvoir le mettre à la vente
évidemment vous serez appelé aussi à
être vendeur donc à savoir vendre le
produit accueillir le client connaître
toutes les spécificités du magasin du
logiciel c'est un métier très
intéressant très complet si vous êtes
motivé et que ce poste vous intéresse
n'hésitez pas contactez-nous